moment de répit pour ses soldats
Ukrainiens prison charge dans ce centre
de remise en forme situé dans la région
de carquive quelques jours durant
lesquels l'objectif est de réparer les
corps et soulager les esprits
le plus dur dans cette guerre c'est de
perdre des amis plusieurs hommes de mon
unité ont aussi fait cette session de
remise en forme et j'ai vu qu'au bout
d'une semaine il réintégré l'unité
reposée avec un regain d'énergie avec un
nouvel état d'esprit
cette ancien sanatorium datant de l'ère
soviétique reconverti en centre de
remise en forme pour soldats proposent
des traitements avancés
balnéothérapie rayon laser
électrothérapie ou encore thérapie par
le sel des méthodes qui traitent des
symptômes tels que l'anxiété la
dépression ou l'insomnie
nous nous battons dans des conditions
très mauvaises pour notre santé
tout est humide trempé nous vivons dans
des tranchées
nous avons vraiment besoin de cette
remise en forme nous avons mal au dos
aux jambes nous portons de lourdes
charges
également au programme des exercices
physiques pour se préparer à retourner
au front un soin global procuré à ses
soldats pour atténuer aussi à terme les
symptômes du stress post-traumatique il
a touché de nombreux combattants
Ukrainiens après la guerre de 2014 dans
le Dombas et a été à l'origine d'une
vague de suicide depuis juin quelques
2000 soldats ukrainiens ont été prises
en charge dans ce centre
[Musique]